open our school's anger boiling over in
new york city we're frustrated parents
are protesting the closures of more than
1700 public schools this shutdown coming
despite the fact that classroom
transmission
remains extremely low and that
non-essential businesses
like bars and gyms are remaining open
and just yesterday you saw at the cdc
director
saying that the classroom is one of the
safest places for
your child to be and president-elect joe
biden dodging a question about whether
he will
work with the teachers union to keep
kids in school
mr biden the covet task force said it's
safe for students
to be in class are you going to
encourage unions to cooperate more to
bring kids back to classrooms sir
why is
and even though thousands of seniors
died in nursing homes under his watch
new york governor andrew cuomo
getting an international emmy award for
his effective use of television during
the pandemic
an international emmy greg you've never
gotten an international emmy
i know it hurts me deeply cuomo getting
an emmy
for his covid presentations that's like
giving the good housekeeping seal to the
city dump
this guy did nothing nothing for this
city
he ignored the fact that we had a giant
ship that trump had sent here
to to use for patients and it said set
the patients to rest homes we've been
through this
it's disgusting the weirdest thing about
cuomo he has yet to actually
explain why he is not guilty in that
like he gets very upset if you bring up
the rest home
fiasco and the tragedy she gets really
pissed off
but he never says why it's not his fault
he just gets
mad well no what he says is old people
die that's a fact
and you know the most outrageous part of
it is when he gets a law
passed that he lobbies for and that he
gets it passed and signed giving
immunity to all
hospital law owners and all the
executives
civil and criminal immunity in the event
that they're see
uh prosecuted or or sued
for deaths in the nursing homes and then
they kicked back with a 2.3 million
dollar contribution to his campaign for
governor
i mean that's consciousness of guilt
it's after the fact
he gets that gives them immunity they
give money and the corruption goes on
and by the way i have an emmy and i
heard
what about your children and school what
do they have emmys
they have 11.
they're in school they're in catholic
school the way i think about it is this
democrats are like a race car driver in
nascar you know when the
team car has logos slapped all over them
yeah
that's what the democratic party is they
have twitter logo
they have bank of china logo they're
driving around
the big logo on the hood of the car is
the teachers union yes it was the
teachers union
that concocted this artificial or
arbitrary three percent
positivity rate where they have to shut
everything down it's meaningless
they didn't want to go to school in the
summer time
so now they're happy that this got
triggered and
everybody's life falls apart but do you
think the teachers are doing that
because they don't want to work why are
the teachers i don't want to
be having the teachers union because i
am generally terrified of the teachers
union
they're going to come after me but i
will say this the teachers union
leadership
they fought hard against coming back to
school every single step of the way
and they don't look that mad that
they're being sent home and still
getting paid
do you emily do you have big
thanksgivings and i wonder
how this is affecting your plans for
next week
well among other things my dad lives in
oregon so apparently if i went down and
visited him with the rest of my family
we could be fined and or
jailed and that to me is the biggest
irony of all and the biggest guts
crystal meth in oregon and that's okay
that's right that's illegal yeah at
least we have our sense of prescription
and that for over a hundred days we
watched as people
burned down neighborhoods and destroyed
people's livelihoods and their small
businesses
and yet there were zero legal
consequences i mean they were doxxing
law enforcement officers they were
showing up at their homes
nothing happened to those people and yet
here apparently you would be prosecuted
for gathering with your family and i'm
not in any way
downplaying of course the public health
effects of this pandemic
but i don't understand why we continue
to ignore why the mainstream media
and the left continues to ignore those
other effects and that anyone who brings
it up
is is called you know we're deniers
we're wearing the tinfoil hat
and yet all we're doing is pointing out
the spikes and suicides the mental
health issues the social isolation
my friend is a long time uh career
paramedic and she told me that her calls
have decreased in quantity but they have
increased in severity
that people are sitting on their
emergent symptoms a stroke victim for a
week
someone who broke her leg and sat on it
for a week and so it had to be amputated
because they are so filled with fear
over contracting kobit and for not
understanding that hospitals have a
procedure in place
for separating those people who do have
cobit or think they do so that they
would protect the population
we are worse off because of this we're
solved because of
because of that because of all of that
well all of it
all of that everything is ground
here's the thing okay what you stated
this eloquently
you know we're america's backbone is
freedom that's why we fought i mean give
it's give me liberty or give me death
but the reality is it's give me liberty
accompanying with impending death we're
all going to die
between those two polarities freedom and
death is
common sense the ability to weigh the
cost and the benefits
of of doing of taking part in any
activity whether it is driving
or eating certain foods and whatnot but
the idea of
locking this all down because of a three
percent positivity rate
among the healthiest population that's
death i mean that is a metaphorical
death
we're taking away liberty so are you
when you see a spike
in new york and you hear all the panic
and the school children being
taken out of school and all the rest of
it do you have a feeling that here we go
again
is it a you know thanksgiving is
supposed to be such a warm
and uh inclusive kind of celebration
i don't know given given all of these uh
you know these metrics yes the vaccine
is coming but it's not here yet
i mean does it is it deflating i only
trust
the death rate is the death rate going
down which it is declining
and we're even seeing encouragement in
new york right now but we don't hear
about
it because the media chases one number
which is absolute deaths
so we keep getting the tally and the
tally and tally imagine if we did that
every day we told you how many people
died from car accidents and how many
people died from cancer
or heart disease what that would do to
our psyche we would never eat a steak
again
you know mike did you hear my idea about
what to call the vaccine
no because he's not going to get any the
trump yes
i thought that was real have you gotten
the trump i've gotten the you know
you got trump give him trump at least
give him credit
no yeah i think that's a wonderful idea
i really do and you know when joe biden
came out and started talking about it
i don't know last week i was like why
are you talking about it i mean aren't
didn't you all say you wouldn't
trust it if trump had anything to do
with it and and this guy i got to go
back cuomo gets an international emmy
and he said he wouldn't take the vaccine
or wouldn't bring it to new york i mean
this is all
lunacy it's crazy day well he's uh you
know and his dad was so nice didn't you
love his dad
who's dad andrew's dad oh mario yeah he
was okay
all right oh mario i i like